is a type of question that you might see
on an ap economics exam and it's talking
about perfectly competitive markets so
it says a typical profit maximizing firm
in a perfectly competitive constant cost
industry is earning a positive economic
profit
so the first question they ask us is is
the market price greater than less than
or equal to the firm's price explain so
pause this video and see if you can
answer this on your own before we do it
together all right now let's do it
together so remember we are talking
about a perfectly competitive market so
in a perfectly competitive market all of
the players in that market have to be
price takers they have no pricing power
so the market price has to be equal to
the firm's price
so
market
market price
equal
equal to firm price
firm price
because
in
perfectly
perfectly competitive
market
market firms are price takers firms
are
price
takers they have no pricing power all
right part b
draw correctly labeled side-by-side
graphs for both the market and a typical
firm and show each of the following and
they'll ask us to do a bunch of stuff
here so once again pause this video and
actually get a paper this will be very
valuable for you to have a go at this
all right
so let's see we want to do these
side-by-side graphs and we want to think
about the market and the firm and we've
done this in multiple videos before so
let's think about what they're talking
about is so this is the market right
over here
that's the market
and this is on this axis is going to be
price
on this axis is going to be quantity
and then let me do a similar thing for a
firm here
so
that would be the firm's price axis
price
and then this would be quantity for the
firm
quantity
let me make it clear this is the market
and then this right over here
is the firm
and let's see they say market price and
quantity so the equilibrium price and
quantity in the market so we could draw
the supply curve for the market it might
look something like this
upward sloping we've seen that multiple
times we could do the demand curve for
the market it would look something like
that and then we have the equilibrium
price in the market which they want us
to use p sub m
so p sub m and then we have the
equilibrium quantity in the market which
they want us to use q sub m
so we've done this first part
all right now let's see what else they
want the firm's quantity labeled q sub f
the firm's average revenue curve labeled
ar the firm's average total cost curve
labeled atc the area representing total
cost shaded completely
so in order to this first part the
quantity that it would be rational for
this profit seeking firm or the profit
maximizing firm to produce to think
about that we actually also have to
think about the firm's average revenue
and the average revenue which is going
to be the same thing as the demand curve
for that firm is going to be based on
this market price remember the firm
in this perfectly competitive market has
to be a price taker
so this horizontal line right over there
that is the
firm's average revenue are which is
equal to its marginal revenue which is
equal to its demand curve which is equal
to this market price
and the quantity that it's rational for
this firm to produce is where this
marginal revenue curve which is also the
average revenue curve in this case
intersects our marginal cost curve so
the marginal cost curve might look
something
something like this
so marginal cost
and so this right over here
is our q
sub f so we've done this part and this
part
the firm's average total cost curve
well the average total cost at this
quantity needs to be below
the marginal revenue and the average
revenue that quantity because we know
that the firm is earning a positive
economic profit
so
we are dealing with a situation that
likely looks like this so the average
total cost
might look something
like this and i drew it that way
to ensure that at this quantity q sub f
our marginal revenue and our average
revenue is above our average total cost
that tells us that we're earning
economic profit in this situation so
i've done part four the area
representing total cost shaded
completely
well the area representing total cost
would be the cost per unit the average
cost per unit which is that much times
the total number of units and the total
number of units is
is going to be this length which is
equal to q sub f and so your total cost
is going to be this shaded area if they
were asking us our total economic profit
then we would be talking about this area
up here but they're not they're talking
about our total cost which is this area
right over there so we have done those
parts now let's go to part c
if one firm in the market were to raise
its price what would happen to its total
revenue explain pause this video see if
you can answer that
remember we're dealing with a perfectly
competitive market a perfectly
competitive industry there's no
differentiation between anyone's
products so if all of a sudden someone
were to stick their head out and try to
raise price no one would buy their
product anymore because people can get
identical products from other people for
a lower price and so its total revenue
its
total
revenue
would
go
to
zero
since
product
is undifferentiated
differentiated
and consumers
could
buy
from
others
at lower price
at lower
price
and another this is another way to think
about it that you know they have to be
price takers in a perfectly competitive
market